foreign
this system as applied in Henderson was
rigged against her
and racist oh absolutely
the attorney for a former Henderson
police chief says he's got the goods
against the city asking a federal court
judge to find that the chief's gender
and race were attacked the whole time
she was employed and then she was
wrongfully terminated the eight news now
investigators have been scouring the
most recent court filings on this and
they obtained audio recordings that
poked some holes in the chief's
termination letter eight news now
investigator Kyle Payne here with a look
at both sides of the legal battle it's a
court case that's been dragging on since
2020 heating up and now both sides have
filed motions for a federal court judge
to find in their paper both sides
essentially saying they have the other
right where they want them
this system as applied in Henderson was
rigged against her and racist oh
absolutely the attorney for former
Henderson police chief Leticia Watson
standing by his client and most recently
an emotion in federal court Mark cook
claims he can prove his case against the
city try and dissect whether that is
racially motivated or gender motivated I
believe it's both
and I believe uh you know the the facts
will bear that out the same facts both
sides are using in dueling motions for
summary judgment if either motion is
successful that likely clears the path
for one side to win this lawsuit which
alleges racial discrimination violation
of civil rights and infliction of
emotional distress and that the police
Union was out to get the former Chief
they said one of the reasons for
termination is you advised you were at
war with the union and that's baloney
we've got them on tape the eight news
now investigators also have him on tape
former city manager Bristol Ellington
who in Watson's termination letter said
it was Watson's war with the police
Union that led to her termination
actually said in a quarterly review of
Watson less than a month before she was
fired that it was all the union I
personally think they're out
um
Fallout War to get rid of you and get
rid of her they did replacing her with
another Chief Cedric Andres who's also
on his way out come Tuesday after his
own skirmishes with the union he was
deposed in the Watson case as well
another police chief exiting Henderson
the seventh police chief there since
2005 and Watson's attorney says a huge
part of the problem is Watson's
complaints of racism and other
mistreatment went unanswered while the
city spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars investigating her every time
someone else made any sort of complaint
and she didn't even get the first part
of the investigation going but everybody
else did everybody else did
I asked the city of Henderson for
comment and they said they don't comment
on pending litigation attorneys for the
former and current Henderson employees
being sued directed me back to the
recent court filings the next phase of
motions in this case is due on March
15th
and after chief Watson left Henderson
she was hired by the city of Sacramento
to run the Office of Public Safety
accountability she is no longer a police
officer